um hey guys so today i'm going to talk
to you
about my experiences monitoring models
and production
i'm lena i'm the machine learning lead
engineer at the cabi bank here in berlin
before i was a senior research engineer
at salando
and you might be wondering what the 30
models were about so it was a variety of
models
a lot of recommender systems
personalization
nlp in customer service and some finance
related models and they're mostly
large-scale production systems so i hope
what i learned can be useful for you
okay so if you look at
some of the machine learning tooling you
might get a little overwhelmed because
the space is really large developing
kind of fast and there are many
different tools out there
so what i'm showing you today is my
monitoring blueprint which is a much
simplified version that i found useful
for my projects in production so i will
cover first
implementing basic software back-end
monitoring
and then adding ml monitoring and how
you can use relatively simply tooling to
do it
so let's start with the basic software
monitoring
so
i want to cover the basis here
especially for the pure data scientists
maybe lacking a little bit of production
experience
and that's why i'm going to cover it
real brief so
um
everybody experiences incidents so even
the really big professional software
companies like google or aws have
regular incidents that's why they have a
health dashboard where they show okay
this service is experiencing slow down
or worse and this is when it's coming
back up so you can see that this is
unavoidable it's an unavoidable problem
that you will have problems and the
difference between the good companies
and the companies which are could
improve still a little bit is that you
detect it fast
and that you act
on these problems based on their
severity
so you want to know are your customers
experience slow down
or do they get weird responses
and maybe you're even losing money
immediately or one of your customers is
losing money so it's really important
that you detect fast and then you act
based on the severity
typically there are three types of
severities there's like severity level
one which is critical with a high impact
and you need to to react immediately
then you have level two which is major
and significant and you wanna react kind
of fast but you have a little bit more
time
and then there's level three it's a bit
more minor so you have more time to fix
it but you still want to detect it
so what do we so how fast do you serve a
request
the traffic how much requests do you get
per second and the errors so do any of
these requests fail
and fourth signal is saturation which
means what's the load on your network
and on your service
as you can see we're focusing on
symptoms of something not the cause
so this means
probably your end users are feeling some
pain if you get one of these alerts so
they have a slow down or they're
experiencing errors
and if you have
saturation gives an error it means the
pain is coming soon and you get a bit of
a head start
um i recommend to use this for all of
your products
this also applies in the batch use case
so if you don't have a production
service that gets regular requests but
you process it in batch let's say once a
night
um you still want to check your latency
so how much time do you typically take
and monitor it if it takes usually an
hour and then it suddenly takes six
hours you wanna know that is it in time
for when your customers want to consume
your predictions
traffic is identical how much traffic do
you get is it sometimes a lot more a lot
less that can point to a problem
and errors especially interesting in
batch processing libraries handle this
differently some libraries fail if
there's one point in the batch
that has an issue and other libraries
just silently eat this error
or give you a warning that you might
miss so you want to find out how to
collect these errors and have them as a
metric
okay so how can you monitor these for
metrics these are like the ground
metrics that you should have typically
you have a live dashboard this is one i
brought to you
this particular one is grafana but there
are many different dashboard tools you
can also play with it it's at
play.grafana and you can google for the
four golden signals so you can play with
this dashboard
you can adjust the time frame it's
really neat
and
we typically use that to show your
performance over time
or check possible issues during an
incident and you can also use it to do
regular re performance reviews of your
application so how fast is it does it
have spikes
et cetera
and next what you do is if you have such
metrics is you
put an alert so alert means you want to
get notified if
one of these metrics is too high or too
low i put here an example by cloudwatch
which is by aws but many different
vendors so whatever you have will
probably have a similar functionality
there's also one in graffana you can
basically say this is the metric and if
it is over or under this threshold
please alert me and then you have
different options you can get an sms an
email
a pager
and if it's an important alert this
often goes to 24 7 on call people who
immediately look at your application for
example it's down and it shouldn't be
down
but then there are other alerts maybe
you fix them when you come into the
office um the next day
so
is traditional this kind of traditional
monitoring enough for machine learning
applications
um i brought you a picture here from a
google paper called machine learning
test score for production
and you can see that the complexity of
machine learning applications is higher
than classic back-end software
engineering
and that's mostly because they're
diverse data related things that you
have to monitor for example the data
itself
skew between training and production
the model model updates the model
training pipelines etc
so you can see it becomes more complex
and i can testify to that from my
personal experience that we had
diverse set of bugs that were not
covered by the traditional monitoring
and i gave you give you some examples
here
for example what happens
what can happen is that the input data
changes
so the client called us and it was a
fraud model and for some reason the unit
of one of the numerical input was
changed and this doesn't give an
exception because it's still a number
but the unit changed from seconds to
milliseconds
and this was a very important feature so
the model
immediately lost prediction quality and
this caused a lot of commercial
yeah commercial costs because fraud was
not detected
and
as you can see from the previous
monitoring slide this wouldn't be
covered
another time we
had an external service which migrated
their data storage which we called for
to get article metadata and they
migrated their storage and the new
storage had some of the fields
less filled so immediately when we
switched over
to the new endpoint we had
we used these fields and they were less
filled so immediately we had quality
degradation so we could detect and
switch back and tell them to please
populate these fields before we try this
again
another reason is aggressive post
filters so in many applications you have
the model but then there are some
filters applied on top of what your
model says
for example we had the case where this
was an optional field and if it's an
optional field and it's not there nobody
is going to log a warning so if it goes
away over time you want to know that
another another example is we had an on
sale filter that worked really well when
it was created which happened to be
doing sales season and then we moved
into non-sales season there were barely
any articles on sale so this module
looked really bad
so how are you going to detect this
and then i have some other examples you
can have some bugs in your own code like
simple bugs like we wanted to get the
last 10 orders but we got the last 10
articles instead so just mistakes you
make
or the model is automatically trained
and released if you have continuous
release of models but the newest batch
is worse for example because the
training data had a problem and you
didn't catch it
we also had funny examples where the
tensorflow version was updated and we
didn't have it properly pinned so you
can have all kinds of these issues in
production and the last example is
especially in bigger companies or when
your client is external they don't
always tell you how they're going to use
your model downstream so sometimes they
make changes in this case the client
suddenly used the model in the non-login
area so we got a bunch of completely
differently distributed traffic than we
got before and maybe you need to adapt
your training data to the new situation
but you definitely want to know if
something like this happens
okay so this was a bunch of examples
just to tell you that
there's a lot of things that can go
wrong
and none of these are called by
traditional monitoring which is also
important you should have it but it's
not caught these things are not called
and
very funny is that these things cause a
bigger commercial impact than most of
the modeling that you work on so if you
don't catch that you work on improving
the model by three percent or something
like this but such a bug can easily cost
you a lot more
10 percent more and you won't notice you
think it's
devolved over time or something like
that
okay that's why we need additional
machine learning monitoring
let's have a look at the practical
example that i brought that we can walk
through so this is one of my use cases
um
i'm currently working at a bank so we
have some private loan offers that you
can compare we are a comparison website
it's one of our offers so you go to
check 24 for example and say
i would like a loan for my new car
and then
what this platform does it calls a bunch
of banks in the background
and they all call the credit bureau
because they want to know what's your
credit score do you have pre-existing
credits and that's not so great for the
banks because we all call this credit
bureau they all charge us
and the uptake rate of course you're at
most gonna take one credit and maybe
you're just looking what you can get as
an interest rate and you try a few times
so this is very expensive for us
so it would be nice if we could tell
with a really high certainty which
people will be rejected and we reject
them without calling the
the credit office
so that was the idea could we develop a
model for that that predicts if the loan
is rejected or accepted
we have application data from the last
month and we don't know the unknown in
this problem is the credit agency
response so it's existing loans at other
banks credit scores and maybe you
defaulted in the past stuff like that
and we have a bunch of fields
application information like how much
money do you want what's your income
what's your rent what's your employment
status
some configuration from the process age
limits current risk configuration
past applications by the same person and
some other fields like is it a customer
what type of loan etc
so this remember this will be our
example and let's now walk through what
we should monitor for this
okay generally my argument would be that
we would like to do symptom-based
monitoring very similar to what we do in
backend engineering
we want to catch the customer pain
so
i would say we prioritize our monitoring
backwards from the output and we start
to the right and i will walk you through
each of these stages and let's start
with evaluation metrics and production
and stakeholder concerns
okay so a very common question i get
when i talk
to other data scientists
they want to put the model into
production is
is there a way that i can monitor what i
evaluated on the evaluation set also in
production
for example in this case precision and
recall
and
maybe you can it depends on the type of
application that you have
so
do you know the target of your
prediction close in time
there's some problems in production that
where you cannot have it typically is
a it could be an unknown result so in
the case of fraud you get a request and
of course if you think it's fraud
what are you going to do you're going to
decline
this loan you're not going to have a
look typically and because that's the
purpose of the model so in some cases
the purpose system of the model is to
reject something or to make a decision
and then you don't know the target value
in this case you would have an unknown
result
then sometimes you have machine learning
models where you have a delayed result
let's say you're predicting how fast a
parcel is going to be delivered
and you say it's going to be three days
and then after three days or whenever
the pastor arrives to get a call back
and say okay this pastor arrived in four
days on two days and then you have your
ground truth and you can compare against
it but it's delayed so that's not useful
for real-time alerting if you get a bug
or if you release a problem
and then third problem you can have
is sort of a filter bubble effect where
the algorithm decides what to show and
you don't know the outcome on unseen
unseen options so this this means also
you might not know the crown truth for
all the
predictions you might be interested in
so my summary is
you can monitor the evaluation metrics
in production for some use cases like
namely if you don't have these
challenges that i just explained
so if you can you should do that you
should store the prediction and you
store the target when it arrives
hopefully close in time
then you calculate the evaluation
metrics that you also use during model
development
for example this could be a batch drop
or maybe you have an endpoint on the
service that you call
customer click now something like this
and then you have the the metrics in
your application
and then you add the metrics to the
dashboard to the same dashboard that i
showed earlier so you have all your
metrics these class and classical
backend metrics and the other ones
on your dashboard and then you create an
alert
for our example of the loan prediction i
already said actually we wouldn't have
this information because if someone has
let's say a 99 percentage probability to
not get the loan we would reject this
request and then we wouldn't know if we
made a mistake or not
so what we did here is we created the
production evaluation data
of a few percent of users where the
model is called but it's not used for
decision making
and for this data we're letting these
people through even when the model says
99 rejection probability and then we
record the actual result
and calculate metrics and compare them
to the expected performance
this is a dashboard of such a
situation of evaluation metrics in
production so i have precision and i
have recall here
every 10 minutes this job runs on these
people we let through and then we can
have real-time monitoring to see if the
model still works as expected
and we also have an alert so if it
surpasses a certain level
then we
get an email and we can have a look what
happened
okay so let's get to my second
recommendation of monitoring priority
one is
stakeholder fear signals
so often when you talk to stakeholders
they're not only looking at the upside
of adding a model they're also kind of
worried to add machine learning to their
to their product so things that could go
wrong are often front of their mind not
just the upside
so what i typically recommend is that
you ask them for their worst case
scenarios
so
maybe they're worried if the service
makes the wrong decision or they're
worried that it's uncertain or that it's
slow or what should they do if it's not
available if it's down or has slowness
and timeouts
so i would put these spheres into
metrics and demo them okay now we are
pretending the service is down or no
we're having like a really weird input
let's see what happens and then you also
add
these two um
to the dashboard and have alerting so
for example if my loan prediction
stakeholders they were of course very
worried that we would reject people who
would actually get a loan and then the
machine learning model would make wrong
decisions they would lose business then
the people would be unfairly treated so
we added this live holdout set and said
if the precision goes below 95 percent
we get an alert we immediately look at
it
and we could take the model offline et
cetera
and then there's a second fear they were
worried that it would be slow
of course we knew that it wouldn't be
slow but you still have to cover their
fears right so
we added an alert if the p95 percentage
of speed is below for example 300
milliseconds then we would also get an
alert
okay so let's look at priority number
two
and priority number two is the service
response
model predictions and quality heuristics
let's start with an insight that i had
when talking to many of you
that were a little bit confused when i
was talking about monitoring metrics
because they only partly overlapped with
the training metrics
so the purpose of the training metrics
was
is usually to
estimate the quality of our model so
this could be precision recall and ecg
it depends on your problem
and
they're only available if you can
calculate the prediction against the
outcome in production
but if they're not available or not
available in real time we need the
second set of metrics for ml monitoring
which is
monitoring metrics
and the purpose of these metrics is not
at all to measure the quality of your
model this is like a fundamental shift
in how you think about metrics the
purpose is not measuring the quality but
to detect something so this means
it's easier they just must be related to
to quality but they're not necessarily
indicative of the absolute quality of
your model
they are much easier to implement
okay
this all the following things are such
metrics that detection metrics not
absolute quality metrics
so one thing you should do is
monitor the response distribution
so let's say your model gives an output
and then there's
a prediction and after this prediction
there could be potential next step like
a filter or some post processing
what you want to do is you cut you
monitor the very last output that goes
to the customer because it when this
thing changes it means something changes
for your downstream users
this is a good catch-all technique
because
you don't need to wait for the true
signal and you can also use it if it's
delayed
this can detect sudden shifts for
example let's say your median or your 95
quantile of your score was at some value
and suddenly it's always been at this
value and suddenly it dropped a lot so
probably something happened then you can
start investigating
what the issue is and it can also detect
slow shifts so if you say
typically we reject
30 percent and then you say okay
once this drops over 25 i want to be
alerted this can be sudden but this
could also be slow over time and then
but you you're definitely sure you get
alerted and then you can have a look uh
what happened
um this is also nice because this
is more clearly
related to a customer experience change
than monitoring the input
if you have so data input monitoring
right we all talk about it but it's not
very clear if you have let's say 80
inputs and one of them changed
significantly you're not entirely sure
if this has a significant impact on your
output of your model or maybe it's a
less important feature so this is very
direct customer related so i would
always start with that as priority 2.
how do you do this there's different
ways to do this so they are the
rule-based distance metrics which are
which is what mostly everyone does it's
quite easy you look at quantiles medians
you look at share of empty or
insufficient outputs
you could also use a distance metric for
example a kolmogorov smirnoff statistic
or d1 distance this is what google uses
in their production stack for monitoring
or population stability index they're
different ones they are some some of
them are quite nice
i gave you an example here so this is
the one that google uses the d1 metric
um it's basically similar to a histogram
comparison so if you have one
distribution it could be your
distribution during training it could
also be yesterday or the same day last
week
and then you have to the right the black
distribution and
you want to measure how much the height
of this bar changed and this is how you
can even visually see like are they the
same or are they different
it's it's actually quite simple but
that's what they use seem to work
surprisingly
okay
then there's a second priority that i
recommend because it's based more on
human common sense which i call
heuristic quality
and it means that you create a use case
specific human understandable quality
indicator
if your response is really good or maybe
it's really terrible or something that's
just based on a common sense
so this doesn't have to be a great
indicator of quality it's just more like
a baseline or something that should be
fulfilled
i give you some examples so when i was
at salando i used something like
this for a personalized use case the
share of actually personalized responses
because maybe we don't know the user or
the algorithm didn't have enough
articles
a really bad response would be if the
response is less articles and requested
or if it's like
a fallback like a top selling product
that would be bad
and
i also said once in a talk by spotify
and they do a personalized homepage
ranking and they had a heuristic that
was
the rank of the users most use carousel
so if you always let's say click on your
favorite band or you always click on
80 songs or your favorite playlist or
something like that that would be your
most used carousel and then would be
common sense if you have a personalized
drinker that it shouldn't rank your most
favoritely used thing at the bottom so
this would be a nice baseline that you
could monitor what's that rank of your
favorite one no matter what personalized
recommender you develop for the home
page you can all benchmark them and if
one of them
a release makes a drop that's probably a
problem
okay and then i have my third priority
that's actually very confusing to me
everybody talks about that monitoring
the input data that seems to be on
everybody's mind but i would strongly
argue to start monitoring your output
data
so for me this is priority three
it's very useful but i would only start
tackling it once you covered your other
bases and you're fine with it and
they're working and you're detecting
things because this creates more noise
and it's not directly user pain related
your your downstream user
so this is also useful especially if
you're more mature in your ops practices
and what you do is um you monitor your
input and feature distribution
and so okay just to be clear i do
recommend you do this but not as the
first thing you can start later and once
you're clear that everybody knows what
to do you already detecting incidents
it's clear who will fix etc okay
so what you do is you compare the
difference between uh tr serving and
training
especially relevant when you go live you
have to do this at least once but for
ongoing monitoring it's priority three
and you can also train on features that
you locked that's in the google rules of
machine learning so they they started
this in
in youtube that they actually got their
features calculated them logged them in
a way and instead of learning from a
different pipeline they learned from
their own features that they locked so
if you have a high traffic important
application you can do that
and you can also compare the serving
distribution over time
especially if there's a sudden shift
that can
indicate a bug and if you can it would
be also good to monitor on sub segments
so sometimes only certain segments go
blind certain countries or certain
payment options or whatever in your case
if you have different clients android
breaks but not ios stuff like that
the same rules apply so you can use the
same metrics rule-based metrics or
statistical distance metrics
okay some hints on how to implement
these ml metrics
do you need a machine learning
monitoring tool there's a bunch of them
in the market they are
full-featured tools sagemaker cell and
then there are special ones just for
monitoring
i'm in contact with many mlm ops
practitioners and i try to find out what
they're doing and it appears to me that
everybody is like kind of interested but
not fully convinced that this is needed
right now
so
my current stance is that
you start simple and you re-evaluate
later if you need one of these solutions
if you have a pure data science product
or if you're starting from scratch or
maybe you're very advanced then you
consider a full-featured platform might
be worth it
but if your customer already offers
monitoring services so you don't need to
set them up some alerting some
dashboarding i would actually recommend
that you use what your company has
that has several advantages you don't
need to introduce a new tool you can
immediately start you have everything in
one dashboard and it's usually
sufficient
unless your type of product really means
that you need to do a lot of machine
learning debugging then probably at some
point you need like more advanced
tooling
and also i think it's kind of developing
fast at the moment maybe give it some
time to mature
okay how do you implement it in practice
an example like some example code so i
use tomatoes you maybe have some other
libraries where you can create a metric
so this is in your inference code and
now basically we move from
batch to single point prediction so it
comes in and then you call a model
predict and you get a score back
and
then you have a histogram that you just
increase say okay now i saw a score of i
don't know
0.3 for example and then you can later
create a dashboard and alert if your
histogram changes its distribution
for more complicated calculations so
maybe you want to do these statistical
measures you can also lock each response
of your model to storage like a database
or maybe s3 and then you run a script
let's say every 10 minutes
and you calculate raw metrics that you
also put either in a database or into a
monitoring solution and then you
monitor on that metric so it's like from
it wise it's not very complicated but i
wanted to show you an example
okay takeaways
um you should monitor the four golden
signals and you should monitor
some machine learning metrics
you should prioritize in my opinion the
output metrics like response monitoring
or if you can
have evaluation metrics in production
and you don't need a new tool you can
use the tools that you already have and
you add a few metrics
okay
so if one of you is now spontaneously
motivated to join my team we are also
looking for a machine learning lead
engineer
and you can ask me privately any
questions and i'm also generally
interested to talk about your ops
practices
and there's a very cool machine learning
ops
slack from people from all over the
world i put you an invite here
and if you want to join it i'm there
different nice people are there okay
thank you no questions
thank you very much lina
so now we come to the q a session um as
i said before we use slido so the qr
code is in front of the entrance or you
go to slido sli do.com
and then you enter pi ber and then you
can ask your question
so i think we have the first question
lina
which metric would you recommend to
monitor model input for perception data
like images
like i said i would monitor the output
and i have not monitored images i would
have to have a look i also have a friend
who works on a startup to monitor i
would probably ask him so sorry no image
based monitoring
but i read yeah
googling but i would focus on your
outputs first if you have that not
covered
okay the next question comes from jonas
uh where do you store your model
predictions including metadata needed
for debugging like model service version
input data etc
relational database nosql db any other
yeah
no we don't store it in a database so we
lock the fee the
outputs and predictions and features
away on s3
and the service version is typically
monitored with an endpoint on the
on the service
yeah
okay
the next question is
how do you prevent alarm hell
yeah that's the whole point of my talk
so if you monitor the output you're
already sure that it is related to
something changing for the customer and
then you slowly start adding stuff
because especially with data
people get very easily fatigued
if there are too many alarms so start
with the output
okay
like the next next question is how would
you evaluate online models
haven't had that case would need to
think about it can't tell you
spontaneously
okay
so we have two more questions
how how do you how do you monitor
fairness and biases
um we currently don't
okay
so okay i can give you a longer answer
for this
so i can give you a longer answer this
is not easy right it has to
you have to know what exactly i'm
monitoring for example i looked once
and we found out that
women get
more rejected in the credits okay but
women also have
a lower income in these
in these
requests so you could make in a
reasonable case that if you have a lower
income and it's just correlated so i
would say fairness and bias is always
very very domain specific i cannot say
that this is unfair right because as a
bank if you have a certain income you
get a certain loan right
so
it's very tricky and you need to make
this very domain specific and you need
to think what exactly you want to
capture and how you want to react with
it so i would say it's a it's worthwhile
undertaking but it depends on your
domain a lot so
that's my more less flippant answer
okay so the next question is regarding
alerts are the ml engineers in your team
also on call duty or
only when the issue is escalated
we are not on call now
it's it's it's a little bit funny i also
always used to think that maybe we
should be also for some other cases but
um
for some reason these data related
products is not entirely sure to
management that is it always that
important and so on because you can't
always immediately see right there is no
one calling the service is not down and
so on but so far in many companies cml
people are not on call they fix when
they come into the offices
okay the next question is
what's uh what's your take on open
source tooling for ml ops especially
metric monitoring any promising packages
i'm trying them all i have not yet seen
one that i find very convincing but
there are some really promising starts
okay
how do you act upon performance decrease
how do you decide to trigger an alert
so normally i just look at the
performance over time from the past so i
either calculate it on the offline
metrics or i can i implement the alert
and look at it for a while and then i
just eyeball say okay this doesn't go
below
90 then i alert on 88 and if i get too
many alerts i alert on a little bit less
so it's quite heuristic
i've seen some slides by berkeley where
someone calls for research how to
optimally
design a
better alerting system but so far it's
just based on looking at
what the metric does and then setting a
reasonable threshold
and graffana just released also some ml
based
detection so they're actually trying to
forecast your graph and to find out when
it's
weird you know so that is also a nice
thing to actually apply machine learning
to our monitoring statistics so i think
some things some cool things are going
to come in the space
okay i think we have time for one more
question
so uh do you recommend outlier and drift
detection to monitor models in
production
um haven't needed it so far
okay thank you very much lina